mesdames messieurs bonsoir brégançon
c'est fini pas de déclaration mais
apparemment comme dit la météo
dissipation des nuages entre le
président et le premier ministre
tennis fantastique suspense à roland
garros
à l'instant même le résultat je françois
jauffret vient de succomber devant le
grand favori le suédois borg
et puis un autre suspense le duel
tabarly cola dans la transatlantique en
solitaire enfin dernier titre la
situation dramatique au liban car ce qui
se passe en ce moment au liban dépasse
tout ce qu'on a vu jusqu'à présent les
cernéens ont déclenché une offensive
générale sur le liban leurs chars lourds
sont maintenant à quelques kilomètres de
beyrouth la capitale libanaise est
complètement isolé ses accès et
verrouiller son aéroport fermé devant la
tournure dramatique des événements
yasser arafat demande la convocation
d'une conférence arabe au sommet à
laquelle treize chefs d'état ont déjà
donné leur accord et pour sa part la
ligue arabe réunir après demain au caire
les ministres des affaires étrangères
voilà donc maintenant un pays exsangue
victimes non seulement d'une guerre
civile mais d'une guerre tout court une
guerre siro libano palestiniennes à
quelques heures de la tombée de la nuit
beyrouth la capitale libanaise est coupé
du monde
les chars syriens seraient à 20 km de la
ville peut être même beaucoup plus près
malgré les violents combats entre
miliciens des forces palestiniennes et
progressistes et blindés syriens
ces derniers ont continué leur avance
pratiquement toute la journée
appuyer le plus souvent par des tirs
d'artillerie lourde
les bombardement qui aurait fait déjà
des centaines de morts sur la route qui
mène à beyrouth
le convoi militaire syrien s'étend sur
plus de 5 km les chars de fabrication
soviétique t62 les canons autotracté et
des camions syrien se comptent par
centaines
le déséquilibre est énorme entre ces
forces syriennes et les forces
palestiniennes et progressistes qui ne
possèdent qu'une dizaine de blindés et
quelques camions
il ya quelques minutes on a appris
d'alger qu'un mouvement palestinien
parlait d'un accord qui serait intervenu
entre les parties en présence ont vue
d'un cessez le feu
et pour l'instant rien n'a été confirmé
voilà jamais en tout cas depuis très
longtemps la situation n'aura été aussi
confuse surtout aussi en bic en effet
sur le terrain que constate-t-on
premièrement l'action d'un pays arabe le
plus dur
la syrie violemment dénoncé condamné
même par les progressistes du liban
c'est à dire la gauche est aujourd'hui
les alliés de damas se sont
paradoxalement les chrétiens c'est à
dire la droite deuxième ambiguïté la
syrie pays qui a sans cesse défendu la
cause palestinienne et qui attaquent
maintenant les camps de cette résistance
palestinienne dans le sud libre
troisièmement conséquences tout aussi
paradoxal aujourd'hui l'egypte rompt
avec la syrie et se met à défendre ce
qu'elle a toujours considéré comme les
génère du moyen-orient c'est à dire les
palestine en fait l'intervention
syrienne au liban est une opération
minutieusement préparé en effet on ne
peut pas imaginer que le président
syrien assad ait pris cette décision
sans le feu vert des américains et sans
l'approbation tacite d israël
car pour l'instant les chars et les
troupes syriennes manoeuvre à 30
kilomètres de la frontière israélienne
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait cet après midi
mais on peut déjà dire que
l'intervention syrienne n'a pas mis un
terme à l'effusion de sang au liban bien
au contraire mais pour l'instant seule
la gauche libanaise détient encore un
pouvoir politique ou plutôt un semblant
de pouvoir politique
c'est dans ces quartiers du port et du
parlement que les forces de gauche ont
véritablement montré leur importance
en effet après de cuir très bas ils ont
véritablement remporté une victoire face
aux cats ayem pourtant bien organisée
aussi aujourd'hui face à l'entrée des
forces syriennes
ils ont l'impression qu'on leur a
pratiquement volé la victoire
dans cette zone foot de beyrouth
même si les combats ont perdu de leur
violence on est entré dans une guerre de
positions forces de gauche etc à tayeb
embusqués derrière sacs de sable
échanges toujours de longues rafales
d'armes automatiques
l'entrée des forces syriennes dans le
nord du pays n'a rien changé à cela et
si les chrétiens conservateurs sont
plutôt satisfaits de cette intervention
qui gèle les positions la gauche dont le
chef de file et kamal joumblatt estime
qu'elle avait véritablement seule la
possibilité d'imposer une solution à la
crise libanaise
maintenant non dirigeant vers une espèce
qui table ronde nous avons proposé que
monsieur gorce avait d'ailleurs
on avait parlé nouvelles accepter cette
proposition de nous réunir à paris dans
un milieu laïque des démocrates et je
crois autour de cette table ronde
on pourrait se mettre d'accord sur
beaucoup de choses nouvelles à condition
que les traditionalistes des deux côtés
soit mis de côté qui sous-entend départ
traditionalistes des deux côtés qui
c'est à dire les réactionnaires
musulmans les présidentes quelques
anciens présidents du conseil musulman
comme monsieur karam et la clique est ce
qu ici
et qui vraiment été des témoins stupide
de ce qui s'est passé sans rien y
comprendre
de même que certaines traditions reste
chrétien
cependant et c'est là la faiblesse de la
ville souhaite elle rester unis après la
victoire du côté des forces islamo
progressiste
on trouve en effet des combattants de 13
organisations qui forment cette
coalition composée de véritables partis
de gauche mais aussi de groupuscules à
l'idéologie mal définie chacune des
organisations à ses propres hommes
quelle armée finances et c'est en
définitive une fois de plus au liban
l'argent qui a permis aux partis
politiques de gagner de l'importance
cela en fonction surtout des armes
qu'ils pouvaient acheter aussi bien du
côté islamo progressiste que chrétiens
conservateurs et ces deux définitions
n'étant formulé ainsi que pour
simplifier les choses
de l'argent on en a distribué à
profusion des états arabes des pays
occidentaux des pays de l'est
de simples groupes financiers le liban
depuis 14 mois
un véritable théâtre tragi-comique de
marionnettes dans les acteurs sur les
libanais mais dont on tire les ficelles
ailleurs les alliances et les soutiens
financiers
ce moment où se dénouant dans les autres
capitales du monde aussi les libanais ne
sont ils pas maîtres de leur destin et
ni la gauche ni la droite ne peut
remporter une victoire définitive et
prendre le pouvoir
brégançon est redevenu désert plus du
journaliste à l'extérieur et plus de
président en plus de prendre ministres à
l'intérieur les deux hommes ont regagné
paris séparément mais qu'on enlève
nuisent rien de symptomatique celle
usage un premier ministre et un
président un public ne voyagent jamais
ensemble
cela dit pour les dizaines de reporters
sur place la pêche aura été minces
valéry giscard d'estaing et jacques
chirac se sont tenues au mutisme qui
s'était engagé à garder brégançon aura
jusqu'au bout garder son secret le
président de la république et le premier
ministre ont quitté la forteresse sans
un mot sans une de ces petites phrases
qui permettent par la suite de faire des
exégèses la seule chose que l'on ait pu
remarquer c'est qu'à son départ ce matin
jacques chirac arborait un sourire un
peu figé crispé même mais il ne faut
peut-être pas quand même en tirer des
conclusions politiques et rien ne permet
encore ce soir alors que la rencontre
est définitivement terminée le dire si
oui ou non les deux hommes sont arrivés
à un compromis un compromis entre la
forte personnalité du dr et les
objectifs de réformes du chef de l'état
compromis entre la majorité
présidentielle tout entière et son
coordonnateur eu des aides les résultats
du sommet de brégançon on et connaîtra
vraisemblablement en détail avant
quelques semaines
mais on aura sans doute une première
indication du climat dans lequel s'est
déroulé le face à face dès demain à
l'assemblée nationale avec la reprise du
débat sur les plus values oui se
pourrait bien que donnant l'effet
jacques chirac acceptent de s'engager
davantage dans le débat sur les plus
values pour faire plaisir au président
on leur a sans doute reprendre en main
les troupes de lui des airs et essayer
de les canaliser dans le sens souhaité
par valéry giscard d'estaing et en
contrepartie il est vraisemblable que
jacques chirac va avoir davantage de
liberté de manoeuvre pour exercer
réellement ses fonctions de
coordonnateur de la majorité on verra
bien si dès la semaine prochaine cette
majorité ne l'est plus de sons
discordants une conclusion en tout cas
ce sommet c'est une petite phrase de
jacques chirac en privé il n'y a pas
très longtemps
il ya quelques heures il n'y a plus de
problème entre le président et moi ça
veut dire qu'il y en a eu
ça veut dire aussi que les deux hommes
sont parvenus à un accord certains
diront un compromis ça veut dire enfin
que les problèmes entre l'elysée et
le parlement ne sont pas réglés jour j
moins un pour la vie politique
américaine demain les dernières
primaires avant les conventions
démocrate et républicaine de l'été en
californie dans l'ohio et dans new jazz
et gerald ford appelle cela la finale et
ronald reagan son adversaire républicain
s'en souviendra car il a failli
aujourd'hui s'étouffer avec une
cacahuète accident banal mais cocasse si
l'on se souvient qu'à l'origine jimmy
carter et planteur de cacahuètes
nous voilà donc grâce à une cacahuète
parvenus dans le camp démocrate pour
suivre un autre duel passionnant
le duel carter bras voilà peut-être
l'homme qui sera le prochain président
des états unis jimmy carter le candidat
démocrate le mieux placé il livre une
dernière bataille en californie
austerlitz où était l'eau depuis février
jimmy carter a gagné presque partout il
a livré 30 bataille au total il en a
perdu une demi douzaine son truc c'est 5
il veut être un homme nouveau un homme
intègre un incorruptible qui va balayer
tous les politiciens véreux qui va
réformer l'état et restaurer le prestige
de l'amérique dans le monde
comment avec quoi il en parle peu il se
contente d'être lentilles politiciens et
en général ça marche mais jimmy carter
ici en californie n'est pas sur son
terrain un front s'est même formé contre
lui à l'intérieur de son propre parti le
mouvement dit ap c est ni bollywood
carter traduisait n'importe qui mais pas
carter ce n'importe qui ici en
californie à san francisco notamment
c'est jerry brown un autre candidat
démocrate récemment descendu dans
l'arène c'est vrai mais avec quelques
atouts dans sa manche car gerry byrne et
n'est pas autre que le gouverneur
de californie autrement dit il est chez
lui mais l'intervention de jay brown est
un combat d'arrière garde
jimmy carter reste le mieux placé dans
le parti démocrate
il est probable qu'il sera désigné comme
le candidat du parti démocrate et non ce
cas il aurait de fortes chances de
l'emporter
et revoilà le général mairie il ya une
semaine à peu près souvenez-vous le chef
d'état-major des armées jusqu alors très
discret était brutalement poussé sur
l'avant scène à la suite de la
publication d'un article dans la revue
la défense nationale un article qui
avait fait quelques bruits et grincer
quelques dents notamment chez les
gaullistes qu'il trouvait trop
atlantiste vient sitôt paru ce document
général mairie parti pour la chine et
son voyage est en train de prendre une
tournure tout à fait exceptionnel non
seulement il a été reçu par le ministre
chinois de la défense le vieux maréchal
genk shining qui n'accordent plus que
très rarement des audiences mais aussi
par le premier ministre ricoh shing ce
qui est sans précédent
il y a aussi le programme de voyage du
général mairie il vient d'assister près
de pékin à des manoeuvres de blindés
chinois il va faire aussi un peu de
tourisme politique à sillans de
l'ancienne capitale impériale ensuite à
yann la base révolutionnaire historique
du président mao mais il va visiter
aussi la base et les chantiers navals de
shanghai
ensuite ceux de loot à l'ancien port
arthur ensuite encore les usines
aéronautiques et la base d'aviation de
shenyang l'ancien moukden et le clou le
bouquet a des chances d'être au msci
honnechy la capitale du sine kiang
province frontière avec l'urss et
surtout proche de la base de fusées
chinoises du lobe nord de là à penser
que le général mairie va assister une
expérience nucléaire chinoise pourquoi
pas pourquoi les chinois qui sont
d'habitude si discret c'est le moins que
l'on puisse dire à propos de leurs
affaires militaires ouvre-t-il six
grandes leurs portes général mairie par
amitié pour la france
certainement mais surtout parce qu'ils
approuvent avec force les déclarations
du général mairie sur la défense de
sécurité de la france aux frontières de
l'allemagne orientale
si nécessaire cela les chinois pour
qu'ils l'urss est l'ennemi numéro un
l'interprète comme une conception
militaires essentiellement
antisoviétique en vérité ce n'est pas du
tout l'interprétation dit l'intention du
général mairie et du gouvernement
français
bien sûr c'est la première fois qu'un
chef d'état major français et même
occidental
va en chine populaire mais à part ce
caractère de première comme disent les
alpinistes
le voyage du général mairie n'a rien
d'exceptionnel il ira sans doute un jour
avec autant de conviction et d'intérêt
aux états unis est naturellement en urss
en reste maintenant quelques
informations la livre reprend du poil de
la bête les banques centrales ont
injecté 5 milliards de dollars à la
banque d'angleterre aussitôt la livre
est remonté très rapidement un nouveau
bilan pour la catastrophe du barrage de
tête nos états unis dont nous vous avons
montré hier les images six morts 80
blessés et 135 disparu enfin clôture du
congrès de la fédération cornec à
strasbourg le congrès a pris un tour
politique l'équipe dirigeante a reçu un
sérieux avertissement
58% des mandats alors qu au dernier
congrès elle en recueillait 72 à
suspense
c'est passionnant qu ont vécu tous les
sportifs il ya encore quelques minutes à
roland garros après une bataille intense
françois jauffret le dernier français
encore engagés dans les internationaux
de france de tennis a succombé au
cinquième set devant le meilleur joueur
du tournoi le suédois org
et encore après un score très très serré
6-3 6-2 3-6 4-6 10-8 portant barbe et
bandeau sur ses longs cheveux bornes ne
s'attendait pas à une aussi grande
résistance de la part de françois
jauffret
en fait sous le soleil d'été de roland
garros banque n'a pas passé une après
midi très confortable après avoir
pourtant gagné assez nettement les deux
premiers sets 6 4 6 2 borg est ici au
fond du coup
geoffrey 34 ans en cumul ne croyait
affrontés pour la première fois board
qui fêtait hier ses 20 ans il l'a
rencontrée sans complexe compensant sa
faiblesse au service et des erreurs
grossières sur des points importants par
un pressing constant et un coup droit
qui a gêné borg
il l'a joué comme il fallait le jouer
évitant de lui ouvrir trop grand les
angles et gardant suffisamment de
fermeté dans le bras pour ne pas laisser
passer ses chances lorsqu après les deux
premiers c'est la balle de bord fut
moins précises les dragues lift est
moins profond et le revers à demain
moins lourd soutenu par les 15000
spectateurs qui avaient eu la chance de
trouver une place au bord du central
geoffrey put ainsi revenir à égalité à
deux sets partout
mené 3 jeux à 0 dans la cinquième manche
par donguy si au service geoffrey dans
ce match aux mille surprises aux
incessants rebondissements
particulièrement intenses dans ce
dernier set et bien jouffre et égaliser
à 4-4
il devait égaliser ainsi jusqu'à 8
partout en sauvant une balle de match
avant de perdre après quatre heures de
lutte
avant de quitter le central vaincu mais
sous les ovations 6-4 6-2 3-6 4-6 10-8
autres qualifiés ce soir pour les quarts
de finale l'espagnol laurent theis et
l'italien panatta encore un tir c'est
aujourd'hui un tiercé moins prestigieux
que le prix du jockey-club d'hier à
chantilly cet après midi c'est saint
cloud qui avait la vedette avec le prix
du roi soleil
vous le voyez ce qu'on aime c'est mais
la sq héros qu'il emporte devant chère
madame et prospérant thèse en chiffres
voilà comment ça se traduit 3 le 11 et
le 4-1 résultats obtenus après photo et
à l'instant les rapports dans l'ordre
8057 francs 50 pour 5 francs et dans un
ordre différent vous le voyez 1611
france 5 ans
et puis ces deux autres informations
sportives en cyclisme la victoire de
guazzini dans la 17e étape du giro j
monde y est toujours maillot rose et
enfin en automobile c'est rené arnoux
qui a remporté le grand prix de pau
formule de prob atlantique maintenant
troisième soirée d'un feuilleton
passionnant qui doit durer trois
semaines
d'abord cette information le français
marc lynch qui a heurté une épave son
safran sont gouvernance si vous voulez
fossé et il est vraisemblable qu'il soit
obligé l'abandonner pour l'instant en
tête
il semble que la cour se réduisent à un
duel tabarly cola arbitrait par
l'américain michael caine sur spirit of
america 1 point en images avec en galets
hier après-midi le survol de la course
grâce à un breguet atlantique de
l'aéronavale nous avait permis d'établir
le classement suivant quand est selon
toute hypothèse eric tabarly et nous
avions pu voir vendredi 13 précédé de
quelques kilomètres jean-yves terlain et
alain colas
aujourd'hui le dernier pointage effectué
par le comité de course à londres comme
unique
le voilier géant d'alain colas serait en
tête devant un bateau qui pourrait être
celui d'eric tabarly
parmi les autres concurrents bien placé
le suisse fellmann est aussi le trimaran
anglais swisher ce pas de nouvelles de
vendredi 13 films est ici hier après
midi mais il aurait été dépassée par un
autre français joël charpentier sur
wayne roquettes
si hier la brise était légère depuis
quelques heures la météo annonce que les
bateaux de tête commence à rencontrer du
gros temps et cela risque d'améliorer
les chances du pen duick 6 d'eric
tabarly
par contre jean yves terlain dont on est
sans nouvelles aujourd'hui risquent
d'être sérieusement ralenti dans sa
marche puis la dernière page de ce
journal c'est une page à laquelle vous
êtes maintenant habitués à la fin d'un
week-end les retours sur la route
d'après les informations que nous
recevons ici ça ne se passe pas bien du
tout
même si vous êtes rentré chez vous la
météo va quand même vous intéresser pour
la journée de demain apparemment sont
des prévisions sans nuages partout nous
dit-on le temps sera chaud et ensoleillé
et températures dépasseront 25 de galles
en or et 30 degrés dans le sud
voilà femmes ce journal prochain
rendez-vous avec l'actualité
gérard holtz à 22h50 rejoindre toute
l'équipe qui m'a aidé à préparer ses
journaux pendant la pente
hot je vous remercie de votre attention
bonne soirée